So, MDS is a group of heterogeneous hematological neoplasm.
They're characterized by cytopenias, bone marrow dysplasia, and a variable risk for
leukemic transformation.
These diseases are generally considered incurable in the absence of a stem cell transplant.
Unfortunately, historically, SCT has not been performed often in patients with MDS due to
these are generally older patients with significant comorbidity burden.
And also, generally, due to the risk of the procedure, it's usually reserved for patients
with higher risk disease or those of lower risk that have progressed.
On the right side of the slide, you'll see some data from the Nakamura study, which was
a donor versus no donor comparison that showed benefit with stem cell transplant in MDS in
older patients.
So in order to better understand the role of stem cell transplant and the outcomes,
we performed a single center retrospective study spanning 2000 to 2023.
To evaluate trends, outcomes and prognostic factors in patients with MDS who undergo stem
cell transplant.
This is an overview of the cohort.
There's a ton of data.
I've done my best to show the highlights in the time that I have.
I'll be presenting some data with high risk MDS, where we identified about 2000 patients
of which 21% underwent stem cell transplant.
We also have some low risk MDS patients were about 9% underwent stem cell at some point
during their disease course.
And I'll also be talking briefly about our experience with CMML, where about 13% underwent
stem cell transplant.
The median follow up time for each of these cohorts is over five years, and we've got
pretty extensive molecular data on a significant proportion of these patients.
So this is the data in higher risk MDS patients.
This is showing survival from stem cell transplant day zero.
One of the most notable findings that we found, there was no significant difference in overall
survival by age category.
These are of course highly selected patients, but this just kind of goes to show that age
in and of itself probably shouldn't be exclusion for stem cell transplant in MDS.
And one of the other very striking factors that we noticed was really TP53 status tends
to be one of the strongest prognostic factors, where we see this really nice survival with
TP53 wild type with 69% of patients that are alive at five years.
The monoallelic TP53 patients, although they did generally poorly, there was this kind
of plateau in survival around 20%, suggesting a subset of these patients are cured with
stem cell transplant.
And unfortunately, the bioallelic patients had the worst outcomes with a median survival
of only 6.8 months after transplant.
And this is some trends over time where we saw that as the observation period advanced,
the median age of the transplanted patients progressively increased, going from 52 years
old.
In the earlier period to 66 years old in the later periods.
And we also noticed this progressive improvement in survival over the time periods.
This is some other observations that I made.
So the plot on the left shows the survival post transplant stratified by pre-transplant
therapy.
In order to make this clean, I selected patients who proceeded to transplant after a single
line of therapy.
We saw here that there was no difference between the untreated patients.
And the HMA treated patients.
Of course, these are different patient groups.
They have different baseline characteristics, so difficult to make a definitive conclusion,
but we do see interesting things here that the patients who got intensive chemotherapy
did it quite well.
These were, of course, younger patients and enriched for more favorable disease biology.
The curve I find the most interesting here is the patients who got the venetoclax based
therapy.
There's a shorter follow up in these patients and the numbers are small.
But this data looks very encouraging for that curve, potentially suggesting that deeper
response with venetoclax based therapy lead to better post transplant outcomes.
And on the right here, we see the survival stratified by the immediate blast percentage
before transplant, where we see there's no difference between 0 to 4% and 5 to 9%.
But those with 10 or more percent blast, they seem to do worse.
This is a multivariate analysis.
Looking at factors associated with OS and high risk MDS post transplant, we see the
most important factor, again, here was the P53 status, but also IPSS are very high risk
and HTCI were prognostic.
These are landmark analyses that are stratified by TP53 status.
The landmark is the median time to stem cell transplant, and I also excluded patients in
the control group that were over age 77.
So, this is just a very fair comparison possible, although landmark analyses are always difficult.
And here we see again, this very marked benefit in the P53 wild type, whereas the benefits
are much more modest than the P53 mutated patients.
Even though in the biallelic ones, there's a statistically significant improvement in
survival, it's only about two months, so in absolute terms, that's quite low.
This is just a slide on stem cell transplant lower risk MDS, this is a very difficult group
to study.
transplant in general not perform up front in these patients. The way I looked at this is I
stratified the patients into the reason they went to transplant. So frontline intent to transplant,
these are patients where there was a clear physician intent to transplant early. Basically,
they treated these patients as a high-risk patient. That group was very highly enriched
in therapy-related disease. And then I looked at the patients that went to transplant for
refractory cytopenia, and then those that went with blast progression, either in an MDS state
or AML state, and then a clonal evolution where there was a new genetic finding that prompted
transplant. And what we noted here is that those that went with blast progression generally did
worse, where the five-year survival was in kind of the 25% range compared to the other groups where
the survival was about 60%. So right now, we're looking into kind of ways to better identify
patients with lower-risk MDS who potentially have MDS. So I looked at the patients that went with
MDS who potentially could benefit from earlier transplant, ideally before blast progression,
because then they seem to do worse. This is a bit of data on CMML. The plot on the left is
showing survival by their disease state at the time of transplant. So statistically, similar
outcomes if they're in the CMML state or secondary AML state, although numerically, the secondary
AMLs did worse. And then on the right side, we see there was no difference between proliferative and
plastic-type CMML. This is a multivariate of prognostic factors in CMML. Here, we noted a bit
of a different story compared to MDS, where really here, it seems the RAS pathway mutations seem to be
one of the strongest prognostic factors. So that's mutations in KRAS, NRAS, HRAS, but also PTPN11,
NF1, SIBL, and BRAF, where patients without any of these mutations did extremely well post-transplant
with a median survival that was not reached.
And then I did some landmark analyses, also stratified by RAS pathway mutation,
where we see that both groups derived the benefit from stem cell transplant,
although the benefit was much more marked in the RAS unmutated patients.
So in conclusion, SCT is an effective therapy in high-risk MDS, being curative in close to 70%
of P53 wild-type patients. Over time, we noticed that it's being offered to older patients with
improving outcomes over time. And then we noticed that it's being offered to older patients with
I think we need some alternative or modified approaches in P53 disease.
The optimal timing of transplant low-risk MDS remains undefined. I think looking at dynamic
risk scores that could better allow us to select patients for this would be helpful.
And then in CMML, it looks like the RAS pathway mutations are kind of
one of the strongest determinants of outcome. Thank you.